back Meagan Marco returned from
maternity leave on Thursday to launch
her smart set capsule collection in
collaboration with smart work and did
she look fierce Meagan has not been
pushing her feet up while she's been on
maternity leave that laptop has never
been too far out of reach the new mom
arrived at the scene of the launch the
rooftop of the Oxford Street John Lewis
in London rocking black jigsaw trousers
from her collection a brown belt and a
white button-down Misha knew new shirt
also from her collection and then paired
the look with fabulous pumpkin coloured
heels and a very sparkly accessory she's
won than before I'm on the tour of the
Pacific and they are Diana's butterfly
earrings she feels that they're her
lucky earrings at one point the judges
took the stage to deliver a two and a
half minute speech praising smart works
and a big piece of this is trying to
transform the idea of charity to
community and guess what she didn't use
notes of course Meghan is the royal
patron of the organization which helps
women prepare and dress for job
interviews as women it is a hundred
percent our responsibility I think to
support enough lift each other to
champion each other as we aim to succeed
her five piece capsule collection which
will be on sale for two weeks features
top British clothing brands including
jigsaw John Lewis and partners Marks and
Spencer and Misha nunu I can report that
the leather is butter soft there's a
beautiful tote bag that John Lewis have
produced and for every tote bag sold
they will donate one to SmartWORKS it's
a like-for-like basis and I have to say
really great quality really great colors
it's a capsule piece that consists of a
white shirts that's been designed by her
best friend Nisha nunu there's a black
tailored suit that jigsaw have made
co-designed with the Duchess a tote bag
and which John Lewis have produced which
is actually sold out
Prince Harry may have been unable to
attend the event but we're told there
were a number
other high-profile guests I was there at
the launch and spotted in the audience
Isabel Mae who is in fact Archie's
godmother although that's been kept very
very quiet she's a great friend of the
Duchess isn't of course she'd have known
all about this launch and mission who
knew who had a front row seat
and speaking of five-month-old Archie
the Duchess made a speedy exit from the
event and was overheard telling a group
of women quote I've got to get back to
the baby
Thursday's launch marks Megan's first
big solo project since last year's
together our community cookbook in which
she collaborated with victims of
London's Grenfell tower fire and it
won't be long before we see her again
the sixes are busy gearing up for their
royal tour of Africa later this month
the couple have been very busy preparing
for this they will be taking and their
new nanny with them they're travelling
with an entourage of 16 a little bit
bigger than the last tool that they did
but I think that reflects the fact that
they're travelling with such a young
baby and they are very much looking
forward to the tour and told they're
very excited about it and print Perry
has said he's absolutely thrilled to be
taking his wife and his new son to I
think a part of the world but he
considers a second home his spiritual
home Megan's never been this is her
first visit